hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse orient comm and in this video
we're going to talk about how to check
the pupils with a pin light so whenever
you're doing your assessments on your
patients you'll want to be checking
neuro status and one thing that I think
is nurses we under use our pin lights
these things are cheap you can get
disposable ones you can get ones that
take batteries they are so handy
especially when checking those pupil
reflexes so in this video I'm going to
go over how you do that and I'm going to
actually show you how to check pupils on
a patient so let's get started whenever
you're using your pin light I recommend
that you get you a good pin line that
shows has a little gauge thing you can
go by that shows you the size of what
pupils are because that will help you
when you're gauging the size of your
pupils a normal size of a pupil is
anywhere from three to five millimeters
and the shape you want them to be round
and what you're going to be looking for
whenever you're shining this pin light
you're going to be looking for a direct
response and a consensual response the
direct response is when you shine light
into one eye and you're looking
specifically at that pupil to see if it
constricts and how well it does then
when you're doing consensual you're
going to go in and you're going to look
at the opposite eye and make sure that
those two pupils are constricting
simultaneously together so you're
looking at two things direct and
consensual then in order to do that you
want to have the room dim and you want
your pin light then you'll want to look
at accommodation this is where you have
the eyes fixated on something in front
of the patient you can use your finger
you can use the pin light whatever you
want to do and you're going to slowly
move it towards the patient's face and
you're going to look at those pupils see
how well they're fixating on the object
are they doing it together
and are those pupils constricting and
has the object moves closer then after
you get done with that you can document
as we know in the nursing world perrla
which means pupils equal round reactive
to light and accommodation or
knighting so let's actually see this
skill in use okay we're going to use our
pin light and we are going to be looking
for a direct response which means
whenever we shine light into the eye
were shining light we're looking at the
pupil to see if it constricts and we're
also going to look for consensual
response when we shine light into this
side and we're seeing if this pupil
constricts simultaneously with this eye
then we're going to look at accomodation
response whenever the patient fixates
themselves on an object far away and we
see how well their pupils respond
whenever the objects move closer to them
so let's get started the very first
thing we want to do is we want to look
at the eyes and we want to see look at
the pupils and see how round they are
make sure they're equal and the size of
them and on your pin light you have
little sizes and usually normal sizes of
pupils are 3 to 5 millimeters and our
patient here size of his pupil is about
a 5 and whenever you're checking for a
direct and consensual response you want
to dim the lights like this and what you
want to do is you begin by shining the
light in one eye and you're looking at
the response of the pupil and as you can
tell his pupil dilates very nicely and
briskly that's the direct response now
we're going to look in this opposite eye
whenever I shine light into this eye and
see how this pupil responds so let's do
that his pupil responds just like the
direct response it constricts and it
dilates back normally and you want to
shine it in both eyes just back and
forth you can also do what's called the
flash I mean the swinging test with this
and what you do is you swing the lie in
between the two eyes every 2 to 3
seconds like this
and you're just watching for pupil
response you get the same reaction now
let's look at accommodating response and
what we're going to have him do is we're
going to hold the object about a couple
feet away from his face and I'm going to
bring it in slowly close to his nose and
have him fixate on the object and we're
going to watch his pupils to see how
they accommodate to that and his pupils
accommodate appropriately now what you
will document is that it's perrla which
means pupils are equal round reactive to
light and has accomodation so that is
how you check a pupil reflex I hope this
video helped you out be sure to check
out my other nursing skills videos and
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
thank you so much for watching